What is up everyone? Welcome to Candid
Truth. We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. We're going to talk about the mark
of the beast. What is it? When is it
coming? What does this look like because
there's a lot of ideas out there and I
was raised
uh in churches that said it's going to
be this UPC code on your forehead and
your hand. It's going to be a microchip.
This thing is going to be a one-world
order, a new world order with a
one-world currency and this dictator
that just hates Christians and
everywhere he's just killing Christians
left and right. Is this what the end of
time looks like? Is this what the mark
of the beast looks like just like the
movies, the Left Behind movies?
We're going to take a look at it. We're
going to get right into it because
I think it's a lot more deceptive than
what we've been taught.
We think that
this dystopian world's going to come
upon us and millions are going to be
deceived into taking a microchip in
their forehead and in their hand and
they're just going to follow suit and
kill Christians and all this stuff and
they're not going to question it. We
know that this is the biggest deception
in human history. This is Satan's final
opus. This is
what's going to take over so many
people. Only the very elect are not
going to be deceived by it.
The very elect I think is much smaller
than we give it credit for. I think a
lot of people think, "I'm a Christian.
I'm a part of that elect." No, I think
the deception is so deceiving that
millions of Christians are going to fall
for it because it's going to look so
good. We're going to go through because
in order to know what the mark of the
beast is, we have to identify who the
beast is and what the beast is and what
this whole thing is about. So, let's get
in this because there's a lot of
prophecies in Daniel and Revelation.
They line up perfectly. They go to they
hand they go hand in hand. You can't
understand Revelation without
understanding Daniel. So, what is a
beast because that's that's a huge
issue. People are like, "Oh, the beast.
That's the Antichrist." Man, that's so
It's it's like it's almost right, but
it's not. There's so many like subtle
things. So, we need to just study this
out. What is the beast? Daniel is the
key to unlocking Revelation. The book of
Revelation was given to John in a vision
encoded in symbols. The book of Daniel
describes dreams and visions encoded in
the same symbols. We must let the Bible
interpret itself and not speculate who
the beast power is. So,
we got to find out what is this beast in
Revelation, but we can look back at
Daniel because Daniel sets the
groundwork. It's it's called uh repeat
and enlarge. When prophecies they repeat
themselves and they expand, it's like a
telescope. You're seeing more and more,
getting more and more details about who
this beast is. If you guys are enjoying
this, please click a thumbs up. It
really helps us get into the algorithm.
All right. So, world ruling kingdoms. We
know that Nebuchadnezzar had a dream in
the book of Daniel.
He had this terrifying dream that woke
him up and he couldn't remember what it
was and he called the wise men and they
were like, "Tell us the dream and we'll
give you the interpretation." He said,
"No. You guys are playing me." He said,
"You tell me what the dream is. If
you're so wise, tell me what the dream
is." And they're like, "Nobody can do
this but the gods." And so, he was like,
"Kill them all. Kill all the wise men.
They're they're
you know, trying to fool me." And when
they got to Daniel's door because he was
already uh in a high position, when they
got to Daniel's door, he said, "Whoa,
whoa, don't be so hasty. Give me some
time. Let me pray to my God and he will
give you the dream and the
interpretation." So, he prays, gets the
interpretation, tells Nebuchadnezzar,
"Your dream was about this statue and it
had a head of gold on it. That head of
gold represented Nebuchadnezzar, the
ruler of Babylon."
And all of these prophecies that were
told in the days of Daniel, the Old
Testament, they came true. The chest and
arms of silver were Medo-Persian. That
was the Medes and the Persians joined
together by the represented by those two
arms. They joined together and conquered
Babylon, which was thought to be
unconquerable.
And notice it was the head of gold.
That's the most precious metal. The one
that conquered it was a l- lesser of
value of metal, right? Silver.
Then it was belly and thighs of brass,
which represented Greece. Greece
overtook the Medes and the Persians. And
then there is this long legs of iron,
which represent Rome.
Then there's feet, partly of iron,
partly of clay. So,
the Bible tells us that it was Babylon,
Medo-Persia, Greece, but then
history tells us that Rome conquered
Greece and that really happened. All
these metals also have a very close
connection with those kingdoms. Babylon
was known for its gold. Medo-Persia was
known for silver. Greece was known for
brass and Rome was the iron age. They
had these iron shields and and armor and
all of that.
Now, if the feet are partly iron,
who is that? That's still Rome, right?
The feet are partly of iron and partly
of miry clay. That's dirty clay.
If God is the potter and we are the
clay, we represent the church. The
church is not a building. It's a it's a
body of believers, right? So, if we are
the clay, he's the potter and this is
dirty dirty clay. This is talking about
a church, a corrupt church mingled with
Rome, a Roman state. It's a church-state
system. So, we're going to check it out
because that's the final kingdom before
a rock cut without hands smashes the
entire statue and grows into a great
mountain that takes over the whole
world. That's Christ's kingdom.
Daniel 7:23 says, "Thus he said, the
fourth beast shall be the fourth kingdom
upon the earth, which shall be diverse
from all kingdoms." So, we know
according to what the Bible says, the
Bible interprets itself and it says that
a beast represents a kingdom.
God always gives all his prophecies in
symbolic visions. Think about it. Beast
rising out of the oceans. Uh when it was
Joseph, he had dreams about
uh stars bowing down to the moon and the
stars and the stalks of wheat bowing
down to each other. And then there was
another prophecy about skinny cows
eating fat cows. And Peter had a a
vision of unclean animals on a sheet
that represented the Gentiles. And then
you had Revelation talking about a uh
a woman riding a seven-headed dragon.
All of this is symbolic and we have to
let the Bible interpret it. We can't we
can't just make up our own conclusions
out of this stuff. So, a beast is a
kingdom.
Now, we're going to go through some of
the markers of this beast because
it is so detailed that there's no doubt
who the beast is. When you look at all
the markers of who this kingdom
represents, it can only be one kingdom.
So, we know Daniel 7:23 says that a
beast is a kingdom. Revelation 13:1 says
that the beast rises out of the sea
and Revelation 17:15 lets us know what
that sea represents. It says that waters
equal a populated area. So, we know that
there's a beast going to come up out of
a populated area and Daniel 7:24 and
Revelation 17:12 says that horns
represent kings or kingdoms. So, now we
know that beast is a kingdom, horns are
a king or a kingdom and Daniel 7:8 calls
it a little horn, which means a little
kingdom, right? Seven heads with 10
horns and one of them rose up among
there, a little horn. Check it out. If
you go to
Google and you search what is the
world's smallest nation,
the world's smallest kingdom, it's going
to tell you Vatican. Look in the search
bar. It says smallest nation, Vatican
City is the smallest country in the
world. History Channel. Vatican, did you
know the Vatican is the smallest nation
in the world?
So, already just using
these tools that we have, Google, we can
say what's the we can we can decipher
Bible prophecy. What's the smallest
kingdom in the world? And it tells us
Rome. Well, does it match up with all
the other markers?
Because Revelation 13:5 and Daniel 20
Daniel 7:25 says that it speaks
blasphemies.
Does Vatican speak blasphemy? According
to John 10:33 and Luke 5:21, blasphemy
was defined by when Jesus said that he
could forgive sins and he called himself
God.
Does the Vatican do this? Check it out.
If you look up what are other names for
the Pope, it doesn't mean just
Pope Francis. It means the Pope, all
Popes. He's called the Holy Father, Most
Holy Father. When he came to the United
Nations, they stood up and said, "The
Holy Father." and they announced him
coming in. That's what they're calling
him in the United Nations.
But Matthew 23:9 says, "Call no man
father upon the earth for one is your
father, which is in heaven." This is
blasphemy to call him your father.
The Jews answered him saying, this is in
John 10:33. It says, "For a good work we
stone thee not, but for blasphemy and
because that thou being a man makest
thyself God." Well, that's exactly what
the Pope's doing. He's committing
blasphemy and we know that that's one of
the markers of the Antichrist system,
the beast system. Luke 5:21 says,
"Who is this which speaketh blasphemies?
Who can forgive sins but God alone?" Do
you know that the Pope says that he has
the power to forgive sins? So, we know
that this kingdom,
Rome, Vatican, the smallest nation in
the world, the little horn, speaks
blasphemies.
When you look at this crown that each
Pope wears, there's an interesting
phrase on there and it says bishops of
Rome, vicar of Jesus Christ, successor
of the prince of the apostles, supreme
pontiff of of the universal church. The
universal church is what they call this.
Primate of Italy, archbishop and
metropolitan of the Rome province,
sovereign of the Vatican City state,
servant of the servants of God. It says
on at least one occasion the title vicar
of God as referenced or a reference to
Christ as God was used of the pope.
So, the popes call themselves the vicar
of God. And if you see on this hat it
says Vicarius Filii Dei. That is Latin
for the substitute of the son of God.
When you break down this number like
Revelation 13:18 says, it says, here is
wisdom, let him that hath understanding
count the number of the beast. We know
the beast is Rome, the little horn
Vatican. If we count the number of that
beast, for it is the number of a man.
Wait a minute, who's the head of this
beast? That would be the pope. So, this
is the number of a man and his number is
666.
So, if we use
simple addition because some of these
translations say calculate the number of
the beast for it is the number of a man,
you will get 666.
This is the little horn that speaks
blasphemies and claims to be God on
earth and forgive sins. And it just
coincidentally his title of a man equals
666 like the Bible told us. The Bible is
so clear on this stuff.
Daniel 7:21 and 25 says that he will
persecute the saints. Did you know that
the Roman Catholic Church, the papal
power was killing anyone that didn't bow
to the papal system? Millions of
Christians were killed, burnt at the
stake because they refused to bow down
to a man. This is
a marker right here that he will
persecute the saints. Daniel 7:25,
Revelation 12:6 and 14 and Ezekiel 4:6
says that he rules for 1,260
years. And if you check it out, that's
exactly how long the rule of the of the
papal system was before it suffered its
fatal wound when General Berthier pulled
the the pope and took him into exile and
that pope died in exile. That was the
fatal wound. But now that wound has been
healing.
Revelation 13:7 says that he has
worldwide authority. Does this system
have worldwide authority?
Hitler's shaking hands with the pope.
This guy's shaking hands with the pope,
I can't remember his name. We got Bush
and his wife shaking hands with the
pope. We got Clinton shaking hands. We
got Bush Jr. shaking hands. We got Obama
shaking hands with the pope. Trump and
Biden.
Why? Why are all the militaries, all the
leaders of the world coming to the pope
and shaking his hand? And especially why
America? Who is Rome to us? Why is every
American president fly over there, bow
to the pope, shake his hand, and have
some little meeting? We got to start
asking some questions.
This is an interesting article from Wall
Street Journal. It said, can Catholic
social teaching unite a divided America?
Man, this was in February 5, 2021.
They're talking about they're just
throwing this stuff out there. Hey, can
we unite a divided America through
Catholic social teaching? I think this
is interesting. We're seeing signs of
the times right now.
Has worldwide authority. Daniel 7:24
says that he rises after 476 AD.
This beast rose up out of the sea that
was many peoples after 476 AD.
Revelation 17:4 says that a woman equals
a church who's arrayed in purple and
scarlet and decked with gold and
precious stones and pearls. So, we
remember the feet of iron and miry clay.
That represents Rome. Iron was Rome. And
the miry clay is a corrupt church or
Revelation calls her a harlot dressed in
purple and scarlet and decked with
precious stones and gold. Holds a golden
cup in her hand. Look at this.
Revelation 17:4. And the mother of
harlots was arrayed in purple and
scarlet color and decked with gold and
precious stones and pearls having a
golden cup in her hand full of
abominations.
This church is full of abominations.
Their official colors are purple and
scarlet. You can clearly see the gold
everywhere decked in precious stones and
holding a golden cup in her hands full
of abominations.
Revelation 17:9 says, and here is the
mind which hath wisdom that the seven
heads are seven mountains. If you look
that word up in the Greek, it's oros.
And it also means hills. So, we're
looking for a city on seven hills which
the woman sitteth.
Look at that. It tells us what the seven
heads represent, seven mountains or
seven hills. Again, use Google, check it
out. What is the city of seven hills?
And it'll tell you
Rome. Seven hills of Rome. This is
Britannica. This is not some conspiracy
theory website. Seven hills of Rome,
group of hills or
on or about which the ancient city of
Rome. So, the city of seven hills
which Revelation 17:9 tells us again
exactly points to Rome. A little
kingdom, the world's smallest kingdom.
Rose up after 476 AD in a populated area
decked with red and with purple and
scarlet and gold and golden cup in her
hands and is the city of seven hills.
Every single prophecy points to
Vatican Rome.
Also, if you check it out, Dagon. Look
up Dagon of Babylon. You'll notice these
fish head
uh iconographies here and it says Dagon
was originally a Babylonian fertility
god. Now, when you look in the book of
Revelation, it talks about come out of
Babylon, right? Babylon doesn't exist
today. Why is it talking about Babylon?
Because remember, Revelation is
symbolic. There's not really a woman
standing on the moon clothed with the
sun. There's not really a harlot
drinking blood on a seven-headed dragon.
This is all symbolic. So, when it says
come out of Babylon, come out of her, my
people, it's symbolic for this corrupt
church that's going on. Now, look at
this. The the king of Babylon, these
priests that were wearing this fish
head. Do we see that happening in the
Catholic Church? Yes. It's the exact
garb that they're still wearing to this
day. Nothing has changed about this
system. This church system is literally
Babylon veiled in Christianity because
that's how Satan is going to deceive the
whole world. He's using something that
looks Christian
to deceive even the very elect if it
were possible. But I believe that elect
is very, very small because the majority
of the Christian world look at the
Catholics and they say, you know what?
They're they have a little bit different
beliefs, but they're still our brothers
and sisters in Christ. You know, there's
nothing different. And they're literally
the beast system. That's how Satan is
deceiving the entire world. He took the
Babylonian
system of worship, veiled it in
Christianity, included idol worship and
Sunday worship and all these things that
originated from paganism and has most of
the Christian world doing the same
thing. Crazy.
Daniel 7:25 says that this system will
think to change times and laws. That's a
marker of the Antichrist in Daniel 7:25.
He will think to change times and laws.
The pope has the power to change times
and abrogate laws. Oh my goodness. It's
like they were reading straight out of
Daniel.
And literally telling you the pope is
the Antichrist. The pope has has power
to change times and abrogate laws and to
dispense with all things even the
precepts of Christ.
Oh my goodness.
Talk about blasphemy. The pope has
authority and has often exercised it to
dispense with the command of Christ. So,
this pope is saying I am Christ on
earth. I'm the vicar of Christ. I can
change times and laws. I can do whatever
I want and all the world will listen to
me. You know that the Catholic Church is
the world's largest denomination,
Christian denomination. The world's
largest   Christian
denomination is the beast system. The
dragon is deceiving the whole world
right now. And how many of these other
churches are the daughters of the
harlot?
The mother of harlots means that she's
got daughters because she's a mother.
Check it out. Our Sunday Visitor. This
is a a Catholic publication. It says,
Protestants do not realize that by
observing Sunday, they accept the
authority of the spokesperson
of the church, the pope. You know why?
Because when the pope said he has power
to change times and laws, he changed the
fourth commandment. The fourth
commandment to remember the Sabbath day,
which is a times. The only commandment,
the only law that is both a law and a
time is the Sabbath commandment. This is
crazy. We're going to show you more and
more in this.
Of course, the Catholic Church claims
that the change Saturday Sabbath to
Sunday was her act.
And the act is a mark of her
ecclesiastical authority in religious
things. They're coming right out and
telling you, "Look, we're blasphemous.
I proclaim to be Christ on Earth. I can
change any time in law, even if it's the
Ten Commandments. And the fact that I
can do that is our mark of authority."
The Catholic Church tells you that the
beast himself is telling you, "My mark
is that I have authority to change the
Sabbath day."
Crazy. Boom. What?
Sunday is our mark of authority.
The church is above the Bible.
And this transference of Sabbath
observance is proof of that fact. So,
they're saying, "We
We'll prove that we're God on Earth. I
can prove I'm God on Earth. Look at
this. I'm going to change the day. I'm
going to change the Sabbath day, and the
whole world will obey. Bow in
obedience." Just like this quote back
here said.
It said, "Protestants do not realize
that by observing Sunday, they accept
the authority of the spokesperson of the
church, the Pope. Because God says,
'Remember the Sabbath day' in the fourth
commandment, not the Mosaic law. The
fourth eternal
commandment."
We're going to build the case on this
because some people think that we live
under the nine commandments of God
instead of the Ten Commandments of God.
This is crazy.
How bold they are about it. Check it
out. Exodus 20:8-11 says, "Remember the
Sabbath day." You know why? Because God
knew it was going to be forgotten. So,
he's going to put it right there in the
law. Remember the Sabbath day to keep it
holy. The seventh day is the Sabbath of
the Lord thy God. The Lord blessed the
Sabbath day and hallowed it. When did he
bless it and hallow it? Answer the
question. When did he bless it and
hallow it?
We're going to check it out. It was in
Genesis 2 2 and 3. It says, "And on the
seventh day, God ended his work which he
had made, and he rested on the seventh
day from all his work
which he had made. And God blessed the
seventh day and sanctified it because
that in it he rested from all his work
which God had created and made."
So, what this verse is saying is that
God made every day of creation, six days
of creation, then God rested. He didn't
have to rest. He did it to show us how,
you know, he he walks out his law
perfectly. That's what Jesus said. He
said, "I came not to destroy the law,
but to fulfill it, to walk it out
perfectly." And so, Christ when I
believe Christ was the one who is the
creator, when he was creating for six
days, he rested on the seventh day
and blessed it and hallowed it. You know
what? That was before a single Jew
existed on Earth. That was before sin
existed on Earth.
This was in a perfect sinless world. God
blessed the seventh day, rested on it,
and that was part of the commandment. A
lot of people think that the Ten
Commandments didn't come until Moses got
them on the mountain in Exodus 20, but
if that were the case, then how did Cain
commit murder? Because murder is the
sixth commandment. These commandments
are eternal. Eternal past and eternal
future. Lucifer
put himself above God, which is breaking
the the first commandment. That's how it
was a sin because the law existed. So,
Lucifer broke the first commandment.
Cain broke the sixth commandment. Uh
Joseph said, "I will not commit adultery
with Potiphar's wife." He knew adultery
was breaking the seventh commandment.
Why? Because the commandments have
always existed. It's nothing new.
We're going to look at how the Sabbath
actually came before the Ten
Commandments were written in stone.
The Ten Commandments were written in
stone in Exodus chapter 20. Now, look at
this. Exodus chapter 16. That's four
chapters before the Ten Commandments
were written in stone, before Moses went
up on the mountain. And it says, "There
went out some of the people on the
seventh day." Notice it says at the
seventh day
"for to gather, and they found none. And
the Lord said unto Moses, 'How long
refuse ye to keep my commandments and my
laws? The Lord hath given you the
Sabbath.'"
Oh my goodness. "He giveth you on the
sixth day the bread of two days." So,
God's saying, "Look, gather every day,
but don't gather enough for tomorrow
just because it'll worms will be in that
manna.
But every day gather up the manna and
eat it that day, and then the next day
you're going to gather it. But on
Friday, on the sixth day, I'm going to
give you a double portion because I
because I'm commanding you don't gather
on the Sabbath." Actually, there wasn't
any manna on the Sabbath. And when was
it? It says right there. On the seventh
day.
It literally says the seventh day.
"And how long are you going to refuse my
commandments and my laws because I have
given you the Sabbath."
So, God mentions the first mention of
Sabbath by name
is before the Ten Commandments were
written in stone. But remember, we saw
that
Jesus blessed the seventh day and
hallowed it on the seventh day of
creation. So, it already existed, but
this is just more proof.
And
we see right here that in Genesis 26:5,
it says,
"Because that Abraham obeyed my voice
and kept my charge, my commandments, my
statutes, and my laws."
This is Abraham was before Moses.
Abraham existed before Moses, and yet
God said that Abraham kept my
commandments.
So, God's commandments existed before
they were written in stone and given to
Moses on the mountaintop. This is
interesting stuff.
Um and if you read Isaiah 66:22-23,
it tells us that Sabbath is going to be
kept for all eternity. Check it out.
"For as the new heavens and the new
Earth which I will make." So, he's
saying that this is future. This is a
prophecy of the future. I'm going to
make a new heavens and a new Earth
"which I will make shall remain before
me, saith the Lord. It shall come to
pass that from one new moon to another
and from one Sabbath to another shall
all flesh come to worship before me,
saith the Lord."
So, God is saying for all eternity in
the new heavens and the new Earth,
Sabbath is still going to be kept.
There's a lot of people that for some
reason they think that well, when Jesus
died on the cross and he was in the tomb
and he resurrected, then the Sabbath day
was gone away with. Jesus is our
Sabbath. We keep Sunday because of the
resurrection. It's not in the Bible
anywhere. Nowhere in the Bible does it
say that Jesus is our Sabbath.
Actually, they get it from Hebrews. And
when you read Hebrews, it literally says
that there still remaineth a day for us.
And it says we ought to walk in it the
way he walked in it so that we will
prove that we believe in Jesus, that we
worship him, and that we follow him. You
can make all kinds
of doctrines out of one or two verses
out of context. But when you study the
Bible line upon line, precept upon
precept, here a little, there a little,
by the mouth of two or three witnesses,
you cannot be confused because the Bible
tells us exactly what it means. But so
many churches out here are just making
stuff up saying, "Look, this one verse
says this, so hey, you know, this one
verse says that they broke bread
together on Sunday, and that's why we
keep Sunday because
God changed it." No, it doesn't say that
when you really study it out. So,
Revelation 13:16 says, "And he causeth
all." This is the beast. "He causeth
all, both small and great, rich and
poor, free and bond to receive a mark in
their right hand or in their forehead."
So, we're looking. Where else do we see
this mark in the right hand and in the
forehead? And what does this mean?
Because it's all symbolic, remember? So,
are we really looking for a physical
mark on people's hands and in their
foreheads? Let's check it out.
Worship forced by law. At the Council of
Laodicea,
because this is what we're looking at,
that there is coming a system that is
forced, a system of worship that is
forced upon the rich and the poor, the
free and the bond. And in this act of
worship, they're getting a mark. But
when you look at the Council of
Laodicea,
it says, "The council was a regional
synod of approximately 30 cler-
clerics."
And then over here it says, "Enforcing
modest behavior of cler- clerics
and lay people." So, they enforced
modest behavior.
Regulating approach to heretics.
Oh my goodness. And Jews and pagans.
And then it says, "Outlawing the keeping
of the Saturday Sabbath and encouraging
rest on Sunday."
So, in the past, in 363 to 364 AD, there
was a law that outlawed the keeping of
the seventh day Sabbath.
And encouraged it on Sunday. This is how
we got to where we're at today. Has
nothing to do with the Bible changed it,
but man changed it. And it because of
persecution, we've continued to keep it
because nobody wanted to be killed for
keeping God's seventh day Sabbath.
If you look up blue laws, what are blue
laws? According to Wikipedia, it says,
"Also known as Sunday laws, are laws
designed to restrict or ban some or all
Sunday activities for religious reasons,
particularly to promote the observance
of a day of worship or rest."
And then it says, "They're enforced in
parts of the United States in Canada, as
well as some European countries,
particularly in Austria, Germany,
Switzerland, and Norway, keeping most
stores closed on Sunday. So, there's
parts of the world right now, all over
the world, that by law, they're not
allowed to open their stores. They're
not allowed to buy or sell on Sunday.
In the United States, the US Supreme
Court has held blue laws as
constitutional numerous times, citing
secular basis, even though the origins
of blue laws
was for religious purposes. So,
blue laws started out as a religious
thing.
You will not work on Sunday because it's
the Lord's day, is what they said. But,
that's unconstitutional because we're
not allowed It's a mixing church and
state. You're not allowed to do that. We
need to have separation of church and
state, right? So, they're saying that
these blue laws have actually been held
constitutional.
From ABC News, it says, "German court
enforces day of rest." This was back in
2009.
Many visitors to Germany can find
themselves standing outside a closed
department store perplexed to find that
they cannot do a bit of shopping during
their weekend trip. This is a result of
Germany's long-held resistance to Sunday
shopping, even in the face of growing
conservant growing consumerism.
However, Germany's constitutional court
has now upheld a complaint made by the
country's Catholic and Protestant
churches based on a clause in the German
constitution that Sunday should be a day
of rest and spiritual elevation.
So, in Germany, at least since 2009, I
remember my
uh my dad was in the military. He was
stationed in Germany. I lived there as a
small child 2 or 3 years, and they said
back then, everything was closed on
Sunday that old ladies were s-
sweeping the streets and there's no cars
going and stuff. And right now,
that's the same way it is in Germany
right now. I know somebody in Poland. He
says that there's Sunday law, there's uh
blue laws over there right now. This was
the Catholic Herald.
Obama calls for world leaders to heed
the Pope Francis's message.
US president hails the Pope's
intervention as clear and powerful. So,
this was talking about the Pope's
encyclical.
And we know that America is the second
beast. If you don't know that, that's a
huge study, but check it out. America is
identified as the second beast of
Revelation, also as the false prophet
that causes all to bow to the first
beast, the Vatican.
This article is shockingly prophetic.
When you look, America is the second
beast. This beast rose up out of the
earth, which represents a desolate area,
not so populated area like the waters.
It has two horns like a lamb and speaks
as a dragon. This nation is known as a
Christian nation, but it's not really a
Christian nation because it speaks as a
dragon.
The dragon is Satan, but also the dragon
is Rome, because when you look at the
prophecy, when you look at Revelation,
when it says that the woman was pregnant
with Jesus, and that the dragon was
waiting to devour that child, that was
Rome. Rome was waiting to devour and
trying to kill Jesus at his birth.
So, yes, the dragon represents
Satan, but it also represents Rome. So,
America is this second beast that's that
has horns like a lamb, a Christian-like
nation, but speaks as a dragon.
So, when you see the Pope
sitting here with Obama, you're looking
literally at the first beast and the
second beast. The second beast is
telling all the world leaders to heed to
the first beast message.
The president of the United States has
said he wants fellow world leaders to
reflect on Pope Francis's encyclical.
This is crazy.
The second beast is telling all the
world
to listen to what the first beast has to
say and to heed to his message. That's
the second beast. America's going to
cause all the world to worship the first
beast, Rome.
Check this out on the Catholic Herald.
This is about the
Lau- Laudato Si, the encyclical. And
right here on 237, it says, "Sunday,
like the Jewish Sabbath, is meant to be
a day which heals our relationship with
God, with ourselves, with others, and
with and with the world. Sunday is the
day of the resurrection, the first day."
So, why? What this encyclical that the
Pope presented, this was about climate
change.
Why is this in here about Sunday all of
a sudden? And then it says,
"The law of weekly rest forbade work on
the seventh day." Isn't that
interesting? That he literally says the
seventh day, but then he says that
Sunday is the day of the resurrection,
the first day. So, why are we mixing
these up?
"And so, the day of rest centered on the
Eucharist." Oh my goodness, the
Eucharist is completely Catholic.
So, we're talking about the You know
what Catholicism means, what Catholic
means? It means universal.
They From the beginning, this was the
plan to be the universal one world
church. All the leaders of the world go
and shake the hand of the Pope. The
second beast, Obama, the
America, is saying, "All world leaders,
listen to what the Pope is saying with
this encyclical. The deadly wound is
healed." And this is coming.
"The day of rest centered on the
Eucharist sheds its light on the whole
week and motivates us to greater concern
for nature and the poor." See, this is
how deceptive it is.
It's going to look like peace and
safety. Remember, the Bible says, "When
he says peace and safety, sudden
destruction will come upon them, like a
woman that travails with child." So,
this isn't going to be like the movies,
the Left Behind movies, where it's this
one world tyrannical dictator and he
hates Christians and he's killing
Christians in the streets. And if you
don't take this microchip off with your
head, no.
This is going to look like revival. It's
going to look like the world's getting
back to God, finally. It's going to
happen when the world is in utter chaos.
Are we there right now?
Are we there when there's 86 genders and
no one knows what gender they are and uh
there's pandemics and there's famines
and there's natural disasters all over
the world. We are literally there. Every
sign that Christ said is happening right
now.
And the stage is being set for us to
accept an antichrist beast system, but
it's not going to look dark.
It's going to look like peace and
safety, and Satan's going to come out
like Christ himself, and he's going to
be performing miracles. It says,
"Miracle-working demons in the last
days, bringing fire down from heaven."
Miracles. How are we going to
point at someone like that and say, "You
know that's Satan, not Jesus?"
All the world, including atheists, are
going to be convinced at this point that
Satan is Christ because they're they're
believing their senses. They're seeing
he's performing miracles. He's doing all
these great signs and wonders. And look,
the world is the best it's ever been.
We're peace and coexist and we accept
each other and, you know, the Pope had a
commercial that said, "All religions are
the same." He said,
he had a Jewish and a a Buddhist and a
Muslim and a Christian, and they all put
their little icons together in their
hands, the cross and a Buddha statue and
these beads and everything, and it said,
"We all serve the same God, love."
This is how deceptive it is. It's going
to look like love.
Love is love, right? That's what we keep
seeing these slogans, right? And the
flag hanging in the church that's
literally pride, it's Lucifer's flag.
Hanging and adding more and more colors
and people to that. Now, it's not just
the LGBT community, now it's
uh we're going to add the Black Lives
Matter and the brown and all this stuff.
We're including everybody.
It's pride. Pride was what caused
Lucifer to fall. Pride cometh before the
fall. We are ready to fall. We are ready
to be deceived
if we don't know the truth. And that's
what we're talking about here, the
candid truth. Revelation 14:9 says, "And
the third angel followed with them
saying with a loud voice, if any man
worship Notice, this is about worship.
This isn't about some one world currency
that everybody's going to be forced to
take in their hand and in their
forehead. This isn't a microchip. This
is about worship. If any man worships
the beast and his image and receives his
mark in his forehead or in his hand."
Remember, it's symbolic. What does it
mean? We're going to look into that.
What does it mean to have a mark
symbolically in your forehead and in
your hand?
Revelation 20:4 says, "And I saw the
souls of them that were beheaded for the
witness of Jesus and for the word of God
and which had not worshipped the beast,
neither his image, neither had received
his mark upon their forehead or in their
hands."
So, what is this mark that is clearly
not a physical mark?
We know that Christians are the ones
that are going to be attacked, right?
The dragon is wroth with the woman that
keep the commandments of God, the
remnant that keep the commandments of
God. So,
if this beast system is rounding up
Christians
and pulling them in a prison cell, don't
you think that they would be
microchipping them, implanting their
hand against their will like cattle?
Yes. Do we think that your salvation can
be jeopardized because someone
forcefully injects your palm, your hand,
or your forehead with a microchip. No,
it goes against everything that
scripture says. Salvation is a
relationship with Jesus. Nothing can
pluck us from his hand. No one can pluck
him from pluck us from his hand.
Only you can decide to turn your back on
God and walk away like the prodigal son.
And guess what? God's going to be
standing there with arms wide open
waiting for you to return. But if you
don't return and then you've walked
away, there's no such thing as once
saved, always saved.
Read the 10 uh the the parable of the 10
virgins.
They all had They were all virgins,
which all mean believers and and
Christians. They all had oil in their
lamps, which represents the Holy Spirit,
but five of them fell asleep. And when
they woke up, they said, "Give us some
of your oil." And they said, "We can't
give you any of our oil. You need to go
buy some." And they didn't make it to
the wedding feast. The virgins with oil
in their lamps did not make it to the
wedding because they fell asleep. The
prodigal son walked away from the
father. He was no longer with the
father. When he returned to the father,
he said, "My son, he was lost, but now
he is found. He was dead, but now he's
alive." Those are terms for meaning you
are not saved anymore. There's no such
thing as once saved, always saved. It's
a relationship.
God never forces anyone to be in a
relationship with him.
Don't get me twisted. I will never
willfully take a microchip implant. I
never will. I don't believe that the
government should ever have that much
authority and power over us, but I know
for a fact that if I get rounded up and
injected, I'm still saved. If I keep my
relationship with God, if I stay
obedient, if I trust God and I obey him,
I don't have to worry about the mark of
the beast.
Because the mark of the beast is about
worship. If it's really about a
microchip, then babies could literally
be lost at birth because they take your
baby away and they sit there and and jab
them with 40 shots. You have no idea if
they're getting a microchip. At some
point in time, they're going to say,
"Look, everyone has to be chipped. It's
just the way the society is. It's the
only way we can keep up with people. We
don't do uh social security cards
anymore. We do microchips." Does that
mean that baby is damned? That baby took
the mark of the beast and their free
will to have a relationship with Jesus
has been taken away? No way. It's crazy.
This This means that your salvation can
be taken away by the police who are
pinning you down and microchipping you.
When you look at this mark of the beast,
this word in the Greek, it means
charagma.
And it's a scratch or an etching that is
a stamp as a badge of servitude or
sculpted figure, a graven mark. So,
people look at that and say, "Aha, you
just proved it. You just proved that
it's a mark."
Well, it's only a mark in the prophecy,
in the symbol. Remember, there's not
really going to be a seven-headed
dragon. There's not really going to be a
woman standing on the moon. There's not
really going to be an etching in
people's foreheads and in their hand.
This is all symbolic.
It's much deeper than that. Now, look at
this. This is the word seal because we
know there's going to be some that are
sealed in their foreheads. Do we believe
that God's people are going to
literally, physically have a seal in
their foreheads?
And if you say no, how can you say no?
How can you say that all this other
stuff in Revelation is literal, the mark
is literal, it's a microchip, but yet
the seal of God is not? How can you say
that?
All of it is symbolic. And this seal
is the word sphragis.
And it says a signet, a fencing in or
protecting from misappropriation,
by implication the stamp. Remember, the
mark said a stamp right here in Greek.
So, the mark is a stamp.
And the seal is a stamp as a mark of
privacy or genuineness.
So, the seal and the mark are literally
the same thing.
Seal and mark are interchangeable words.
So,
why would one be physical and the other
not?
We know that we're looking for something
that is a phys- it's a spiritual mark in
the forehead or in the hands. Let's
check it out. Let's keep going.
Revelation 7:3 says, "Saying, 'Hurt not
the earth, neither the sea, nor the
trees, till we have sealed the servants
of our God in their foreheads.'" So, we
know that God's people are walking
around with a physical, literal seal in
their foreheads? No, no, no. This is
much deeper. This is spiritual.
Revelation 9:4 says, "And it was
commanded them that they should not hurt
the grass of the earth, neither any
green thing, neither any tree, but only
those men which have not the seal of God
in their foreheads." So, this seal is
protecting God's people, but they're not
walking around with some stamp in their
forehead.
When you look at the comparison of sign
and mark in the Hebrew,
the Hebrew word is oth, H226.
And in in this word, H226, when you read
Exodus 31:13, it says, "Verily my
sabbath you shall keep, for it is a sign
between me and you."
When you read Genesis 4:15, it says,
"And the Lord set a mark upon Cain." But
what I want you to realize is that mark
and sign sign and mark are both H226.
The English translators decided to make
this word say sign and this word say
mark, but both of them are the word oth.
Now, what is interesting about this is
that it says God's sabbaths
are a mark.
Wait a minute. Could this mean that
obedience to God and his sabbath is
actually the seal of God?
This is crazy. Let's check this out.
Exodus 13:9 says, "And it shall be for a
sign." Remember, this is the Hebrew word
oth. This is H226. So, we can literally
read this, "And it shall be for a mark
upon thee upon thine hand
and for a memorial between thine eyes or
forehead, that the Lord's law may be in
thy mouth." So, right now we're looking
at a mark in somebody's hand and in
their forehead. Isn't that interesting?
That God has a mark that goes in our
forehead and our hand. What does it
mean?
I don't think it's a literal, physical
thing. Deuteronomy 6:6-8 says, "And
these words" Okay, notice back here it
says the Lord's law
is the sign that's in our hand and
between our eyes. Now, it says that
these words which I command thee this
day
shall be in thine heart.
What is it What does God say he's going
to write on our heart?
The commandments. His commandments are
written on our hearts. So, when it says
Deuteronomy, it says,
"These words which I command
they shall be in thine heart, and thou
shalt bind them for a sign or a mark
upon thine hand, that they shall be as
frontlets between thine eyes." Here it
is again.
That God's commandments are to be
between our
eyes in our forehead and in our hand.
What does that mean? Are we really
supposed to walk around with a box on
our forehead?
"If ye shall" This is Deuteronomy
11:13-18.
"If ye shall hearken diligently unto my
commandments which I command you this
day, therefore shall ye lay up these my
words in your heart." This is the 10
commandments.
This is God's commandments that are
written in our hearts.
"And in your soul, and bind them for a
sign or a mark" This is H226. "Upon your
hand, that they may be as frontlets
between your eyes." So, we got three
verses. Three verses in Revelation that
say that the wicked are going to have a
mark in their hand and between their
eyes.
And now we're studying line upon line,
precept upon precept, here a little,
there a little. We're talking about
Deuteronomy and Revelation, here a
little, there a little. By the mouth of
two or three witnesses. Now, we got John
the Revelator, his witness, and we got
Moses, Deuteronomy witness.
So, we're we're studying the way you're
supposed to be studying.
And we see that God has commandments
that are a sign or a mark between your
eyes and in your hands. It's not a box
on your forehead and on your hand like
the Pharisees. Jesus is always
condemning the Pharisees for doing it
wrong, right? They were always
legalistic. They were always adding to
the law and adding to the scriptures.
And he's like, "Look, man, this doesn't
have to do with putting a box on your
forehead and on your hand. That's not
going to save you."
Keeping God's laws in your mind and
doing them with the obedient works of
your hands. The scriptures say,
"Whatever you do with your hands, do it
with all your might."
Right? Whatever you're doing it to the
Lord with the works of your hands. So,
trust and obey. Your beliefs of your
mind and the obedient works of your
hands, that's what these scriptures are
all about. The commandments in your head
and doing them with your actions.
Check this out. This is back to the the
blue law thing. todayifoundout.com
is not a Christian website, not a
conspiratorial website. It's just a
history website. And look what it says.
The first blue law. The reason I'm
explaining this is because a lot of
people say, "Okay, okay, I get it.
You're saying that the commandments are
in our forehead and in our hands. This
is the beliefs and the actions. But how
does that line up with you can't buy or
sell?"
And this is the problem that the the
whole Christian world has. We will throw
away 20 scriptures and hold on to one
scripture. We'll say, "Look, this
scripture says this, and that's how it
is." And you got to throw out 20
scriptures to believe this one thing.
You know there's only one verse in all
the Bible and Revelation that says if
you don't take the mark, you can't buy
or sell.
And people take that verse and they say,
you know what? This is about buying and
selling. This is about currency. The
whole mark of the beast system
is about currency.
Like God really cares about how we're
spending money, whether it's a debit
card or cash. God is not damning people
because they're using a certain form of
currency.
The reason it says you can't buy or sell
is because that's a punishment for not
worshipping the beast. If you don't
worship the beast,
we'll deactivate your card. It doesn't
even have to be a microchip implant. If
we live in a world where currency is
digital,
look, it already happened in Canada. In
Canada,
there was uh these truckers that were
having a protest, and anyone that went
up to that trucker with gas, they had
their bank account frozen
by the
government of Canada.
That's mark of the beast. If you don't
listen to us, we will
disable your ability to buy and sell.
It doesn't have to be a microchip. It
doesn't even have to be digital.
Technically, it could be cash. If you're
getting like some kind of stipend in the
mail every month or whatever, and they
stop sending it to you, it can work on
many different levels.
But I want to show you this because so
many people get hung up on that one
verse.
It's not about currency.
But the this blue law in 1610
was an exact replica of the mark of the
beast. Check this out. The first blue
law, although not called that at the
time, was enacted in colonial Virginia
in 1610. There was no microchips back
then.
And it mandated church attendance at
both morning and afternoon services on
Sunday.
A first-time offender lost his
provision of allowance for a whole week.
So, wait a minute. They didn't worship
the way the government told them to.
Remember, a beast is a nation or a
kingdom. So, this beast said, you must
worship on Sunday, and if you don't, I'm
going to take away your allowance.
You're not going to be able to buy or
sell if you don't worship the way we
tell you to.
Those who committed a second offense, in
addition to losing his allowance, would
be whipped.
When you read Revelation, it says that
they will be persecuted. You'll be
thrown in prison 10 days.
And then it says,
a third violation was, supposedly,
punished by death.
Though there is debate whether that the
accounts of early blue laws were in some
cases exaggerated or not.
So, doesn't Revelation say finally they
will be beheaded, right? If
the mark of the beast system is about
worship, and it says if you don't
worship the way that the kingdom, this
beast says,
you won't be able to buy or sell.
You're going to be thrown in prison 10
days, and finally you're going to be
beheaded.
But don't get hung up on that one verse
that says if you don't take the mark of
the beast in your
forehead and in your hand that
you're going to get uh you're not going
to be able to buy and sell.
It doesn't mean that the mark of the
beast is a form of currency. Get that
out of your mind.
We're We're studying this line upon
line. Check this out.
Sabbath is a sign. Exodus 31:13, "Verily
my Sabbaths ye shall keep, for it is a
sign, H226, which is mark, between me
and you throughout your generations,
that ye may know that I am the Lord that
doth sanctify you." So, as God's people,
he has a sign.
And he says that his Sabbath's our sign.
That's his word, not mine. This is the
second verse that's said it so far.
We got another one. Ezekiel 20:12, it
says, "Moreover, also I gave them my
Sabbaths to be a sign between me and
them, that they might know that I am the
Lord thy God which sanctifies them."
Ezekiel 20:20, "And hallow my Sabbaths,
and they shall be a sign or a mark
between me and you, that ye may know
that I am the Lord your God."
You know why I'm saying this? Because
as a believer,
there's laws.
We have to obey God. It says, "If you
love me, keep my commandments." That's
what Jesus said. And many atheists could
say, "Look, I don't commit adultery, and
I don't steal, and I don't lie, and I
don't do all these things."
A good atheist could keep the 10
commandments. But an atheist is never
going to keep the seventh day holy and
spend it with God.
A lot of people will look at that
commandment and say, "You're trying to
You're trying to put me under the law.
You're trying to uh earn your way to
heaven. We can't earn our way through
works."
The Sabbath is the opposite of works.
It's not works, it's rest. It's time
spent with God. It's a relationship.
Salvation is relationship with Jesus.
And if just like date night with your
wife, if you set aside everything, you
say, "Look, I I feel like we're so busy
that our relationship is burning out,
and I don't want that to happen. Every
Saturday, let's not work. Let's get a
babysitter for the kids. Let's put aside
all the bills and all the errands, and
let's just spend that time together."
Isn't that a great thing?
Any person would say, "That's beautiful.
You're going to do that for your wife,
and you're going to keep the flame
alive." That's what God wants.
We're in this world where he says, "Work
six days." How distracted are we when
we're working and dealing with customers
and
and all the stress and all that. You
know, a lot of people say, "I worship
God every day. I keep the Sabbath every
day." You're not keeping the Sabbath if
you're working.
It says, "Do not work." It says, "Don't
even work other people." So, if you're
shopping, you're also not keeping the
Sabbath. You can't keep the Sabbath
every day.
That's just dishonest.
"And hallow my Sabbaths, and they shall
be a sign." Now, people look at this and
say, "Now, he's talking to the Jews. You
got to look at who he's talking to."
Well, yeah. The Jews are God's people.
There's neither Jew nor Greek. We are
all one in Christ Jesus.
There is no such thing as Jews and
Gentiles. If you're a believer, you are
grafted into the vine and heirs
according to the promise. You're the
seed of Abraham. Don't you want to claim
that promise? I do.
And And I want to keep God's Sabbath. I
want to spend that time with him.
Acts 5:29,
"Then Peter and the other apostles
answered and said, We ought to obey God
rather than men."
We shouldn't be looking at, you know,
well, what is what is my the tradition
of my church doing?
Why You know, every church is open on
Sunday, so I do that. No, this is a
tradition. This was paganism that got
brought in to the church to the
Christian church.
Because during the persecution, they
said, "Look,
basically, Christians were being killed
at the stake.
And
Constantine said, "If you can't beat
them, join them." Because every time he
killed somebody, he killed a Christian,
10 more would pop up. It said that the
their blood was like seed that was
growing. Every time he'd kill one
Christian, 10 more would pop up because
they're looking at those Christians and
saying, "That person has something worth
dying for. I don't even have something
worth living for." And they'd give their
heart to God. And so, Constantine said,
"If you can't beat them, join them."
And so, he said, "Look, I won't
persecute you. You can go to church on
Sunday, the venerable day of the sun.
You can go to church in that temple full
of idols. Oh, no, it's not Mars and
Venus and Mercury. That's uh Peter,
Paul, and John."
So, now today, we still see that beast
system, that universal church, and
they're going into temples filled with
idols.
And they're they're remembering the
venerable day of the sun, and they're
calling a man father and confessing
their sins to this man, and it's all
blasphemy. It's Satan deceiving the
entire world.
Matthew 15:3-9 said, "Jesus answered and
said unto them, Why do ye also
transgress the commandment of God by
your tradition?
Thus have you made the commandment of
God of none effect by your tradition."
Jesus was totally against tradition.
He said, "Why are you transgressing my
commandments
for this tradition?"
Mark 7:7-9, he said, "How be it in vain
do they worship me, teaching for
doctrines the commandments of men, and
laying aside the commandments of God.
Yea,
ye hold the tradition of men. Full well
ye reject the commandments of God that
ye may keep your own tradition." Look at
the wording here.
It says, "In vain do they worship me."
You know how many people I hear that
say, "God knows my heart. I worship
Jesus." Well, he's saying right here,
they're worshipping him in vain if they
don't keep his commandments, and they're
keeping traditions instead.
Is the fourth commandment the fourth
commandment? Is it the fourth
suggestion?
No way.
Jesus on the Sabbath, cuz people will
say,
"Jesus never talked about the Sabbath."
That is just dishonest. Look right here.
Matthew 24:19-21,
"Woe unto them that are with child, and
to them that give suck in those days.
But pray ye that your flight not be in
the winter, neither on the Sabbath day.
For then shall be great tribulation,
such as was not since the beginning of
the world to this time, no, nor even
shall be."
Jesus is talking about the future
tribulation. This is Matthew 24. Most
Christians know that Matthew 24 is a
prophecy about the tribulation time
period that's to come still.
And Jesus said,
"Woe to them."
"And pray that your flight not be in the
winter, neither on the Sabbath day." Why
would Jesus be talking about the Sabbath
day in the future tribulation if it was
done away with?
He would have said, "Look, don't even
worry about it. I I died for that. I am
your Sabbath. Don't worry about that."
Or the day's been changed. That's not
what he said. Said that we're going to
keep it through uh from one Sabbath to
another in the new heavens and the new
earth.
Revelation 12:7 says, "And the dragon
was wroth with the woman." That's the
church. And went to make war with the
remnant. That's a small portion of the
church of her seed which keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus.
So, there's people that say that we
don't got to keep the commandments. That
that's not for us. That was for the
Jews. But this is in Revelation, the
last book of the Bible, and it's saying
that the dragon is coming after that
remnant. There's only a small part of
the church that's still keeping the
commandments of God, and Satan hates it.
And he's going after those people.
Revelation 14:12 says, "Here is the
patience of the saints." Are we saints?
Do we proclaim to be saints? Here are
they that keep the commandments of God
and have the faith of Jesus.
By the mouth of two or three witnesses,
here a little, there a little. There's
another verse, a third verse. Revelation
22:14 "Blessed are they that do his
commandments, that they may have right
to the tree of life and may enter in
through the gates into the city."
Revelation 22:14 is saying that we are
blessed if we keep his commandments. And
it's those people that overcome the mark
of the beast. It's those people that get
to have right to the tree of life.
This is serious, guys. I believe Jesus
is coming soon. I believe the mark of
the beast is coming soon. There's no
pre-tribulation rapture. That's not in
the Bible at all. I got a video on it
that tells you verse upon verse, but the
one verse you need to know is that it
says at the last trumpet the dead in
Christ arise first, and those who are
living will meet the Lord in the air.
The last trumpet is after seven trumpets
of plagues being poured upon the world.
The rapture is at the second coming.
So, if you think, "Hey, I don't need to
even worry about the mark of the beast.
I'm not going to be here." That's a
deception, too. Satan has deceived the
whole world. Blessed are they that do
his commandments that they may have
right to the tree of life. Check this
out. Is there really
a time when a blue law could happen?
When the Sabbath is going to be
enforced, and I'm not talking about
seventh-day Sabbath. I'm talking about
Sunday Sabbath.
greensabbathproject.net
This is all about climate change. It
says, "Is there nothing
you can do about the environment?
Nothing may be one of the best things
you can do. One day every week, do
nothing."
So, they're telling us, "Look, we need
to keep a day of rest. We need to keep a
day of doing nothing."
It says, "Take a weekly day of rest.
Make it a real Sabbath for you, for
Earth. Don't drive, don't shop, don't
build, take a walk, eat with friends,
play or read with your kids, sing,
meditate, celebrate contentment."
Contentment.
They're saying, "Look, just be content
on this day."
Increasing numbers of people see the
wisdom in observing in the wisdom of
observing a weekly day of rest, of
minimizing one's environmental impact.
For many, this has nothing to do with
God or religion.
So, look, they're trying to suck
everybody in. Look, it's not even about
God. If you're atheist, hey, do it for
the environment. It is merely common
sense, self-care for oneself and our
planetary home.
Yet the inspiration of the ancient
biblical Sabbath stands clearly behind
these practices.
And then it look at it says, "Every
Sunday
every Sunday since 2007
So yeah, they're saying that this comes
from the biblical Sabbath but we're
going to do it on Sunday.
Here's another one, Washington Post. Why
reviving a 2,600-year-old
spiritual practice made my life better."
Notice what it says up here. It says,
"Envi- climate, environment, weather,
climate solution, climate lab, green
living, business of climate." This has
nothing to do with like, "Hey, you know
what? I decided to take a Sabbath, and
it really changed my life." No, this is
some propaganda about "We must take a
day off for Mother Earth to rest because
of climate change."
This is coming. This has been prophesied
for hundreds of years, thousands of
years, and here we see it coming.
MSNBC, the right. We're talking about
right-wingers. The Rights Project 2025
wants to make faith the government's
job.
So, they're wanting Trump to become a
religious dictator.
Concerns about politics of this kind
aren't only about the possible return of
former President Donald Trump to office.
This is about the next Republican
president, whoever it may be, who pushes
Christian nationalism.
Remember, when they say peace and safety
when they say coexist
it's not going to look bad and evil.
It's going to look like revival. It's
going to look like finally the country's
getting back to God. Everyone's getting
along. We're all keeping Sunday.
We're We're all, you know keeping the
Lord's day, and people are letting the
earth rest and we're all getting along.
And that is when
you've taken the mark of the beast.
If you believe in this system, that's
taking in the forehead.
If you say, "Look, I don't believe in
this system, but I'll do it just to
preserve my life because if I don't,
I'll be persecuted." Then that's taking
in the hand.
You can only get the seal of God in the
forehead because you are not saved by
works.
But you're saved by what you believe in,
and what you believe in, you will do.
If you believe in God's commandments,
you will keep them naturally.
This is crazy. This is coming right
around the corner.
Project 2025. We're seeing it. You see
the picture right here? This is on the
news. A cross on top of Washington, D.C.
Like this is This is exactly what the
Bible's talking about. Mingling of
church and state, Christian nationalism.
Remember, it's going to look like
Christianity. It's going to look
biblical. It's going to deceive
millions. 2025 mandate for leadership
the conservative promise.
What's in here? If you read page 589.
That's what page this is, 589. There's
this whole part about Sabbath rest. It
says, "God ordained the Sabbath as a day
of rest, and until very recently the
Judeo-Christian tradition sought to
honor that mandate by moral and legal."
Oh, we're going to enforce it. By moral
and legal regulation of work on that
day. Moreover, a shared day off makes it
possible for families and communities to
enjoy time off together rather than as
a tom- atom- not atomized atomized
individuals
and provides a healthier cadence of the
life for everyone of life for everyone.
Unfortunately, that communal day of rest
has eroded under the pressures of
consumerism and secularism, especially
for low-income workers. So, what are
they going to do?
Congress should encourage communal rest
by amending the Fair Labor Standards
Act, the FLSA
to require
that workers be paid time and a half for
hours worked on the Sabbath.
Interesting terminology here because the
next sentence says "That day would
default to Sunday." Wait a minute.
Sabbath
Sunday.
Except for employers with a sincere
religious observance of a Sabbath at a
different time.
An example, Friday sundown to Saturday
sundown. So, this is the small steps.
This thing isn't going to happen
overnight.
But they're already saying "You know
what? We're going to mandate that
employers have to pay their employees
time and a half." Guess what? They're
not going to do it. No employer has
enough money to pay that. They don't
want to pay that. So, they're just going
to shut down.
This is This is how it happens. It's
coercion.
And this is forced worship. This is
forced observance. This is what
Revelation's talking about.
Here it continues. It says, "Alternative
view. While some conservatives believe
that the government should encourage
certain religious observance by making
it more expensive for employers and
consumers to not partake in those
observances, other conservatives believe
that the government's role is to protect
the free exercise of religion by
eliminating barriers as opposed to
erecting them. Whereas imposing overtime
rules on the Sabbath would lead to
higher costs and limiting access to
goods and services and reduce work
available on the Sabbath." So, look,
they're saying nobody's going to work.
No goods and services. You're not going
to be able to buy or sell on Sunday
Sabbath.
While also incentivizing
some people through higher wages to
desire to work on the Sabbath.
The proper role of government in helping
to enable individuals to practice their
religion is to reduce barriers to work
options and to fruitful employer and
employees relations.
The result,
ample job options that do not require
work on the Sabbath, Sunday.
So that individuals in roles that
sometimes do require Sabbath work are
empowered to negotiate directly with
their employer
to achieve their desired schedule.
Man, this is crazy that we're seeing
this happen.
I want to show you some clips. If you do
not believe that this is happening, this
has been going on for a couple years.
This was 2015.
Let me listen to what this lady said.
Senator Sylvia Allen, she wants a bill
that would mandate church attendance.
Dennis Welch joining us live tonight at
the Capitol. And Dennis, she did not
want to talk to you.
Yeah, Brandon, as you just saw, Senator
Allen had no intention of speaking to
us, but later she went on the Senate
floor where she appeared to double down
on some controversial comments.
Probably we should be debating a bill
requiring every American to attend a
church of their choice
on Sunday. That was Senator Sylvia Allen
yesterday talking about the possibility
of forcing people to attend church. But
today she was walking away from those
comments, literally. You don't have any
interest in talking about that?
No.
is your relationships and your friends
and your family and obviously praising
the Lord. And he says, you know what, is
working on Sundays true freedom? And
basically says, you know what, all of
this hard work that people are doing on
the weekends on Sundays is having a
negative impact on their lives.
It's so easy to let just work seep in. I
mean, if you
if you're home on the weekend and you
have you know a job Monday through
Friday and you're just I'm just going to
get some work done. I'm going to go down
to my office, do some work, I'm going to
get this done. And you don't realize
then what it's taking away from that day
of rest, that day of family. And that
hour, that 2 hours just starts to
snowball and I think he has a great
point. Yeah, it's not I mean, what she
does. I mean, Judaism takes this very
seriously. Orthodox Jews do not mess
around and I admire this so much about
the Sabbath. Mhm. And again and again
you see this in the Old and New
Testaments. Keep the Sabbath holy. Don't
work. It's it's almost like people it's
baked in, have always had this
temptation to let work crowd out all the
other things that matter. Family, faith.
And they have to be told again and
again, knock it off. Don't work. It's
interesting. You think people are lazy,
but they work too much.
And it's so cool when you see businesses
like Chick-fil-A on this fried chicken
national holiday yesterday uh that they
are not open on Sundays and a lot of
people give them business on the other 6
days of the week because they believe in
that policy as well. But when you're
driving around and you're on a road trip
on a Sunday and you see the lights are
dark. Yeah, they're closed on Sunday.
Yeah, they're still closed on Sunday.
one of the few companies. I mean, it's
disappointing. What we're talking about
is here the holidays, too. I mean, all
Notice at the bottom it says closed on
Sunday, no work Sundays, not just for
the faithful. That's what the Pope said.
This was years ago.
This stuff has been happening, small
little steps, incremental steps, and now
here we are, 2025 with Project 2025, a
new Trump was going to be elected
because the pendulum was swinging that
way. We live in an environment that is
utter chaos. The world is in utter chaos
looking for a savior. We need something
to change. And this is exactly what's
coming.
They're they're telling us that the
climate is
you know, changing and that when COVID
happened and people were forced to stay
indoors that they saw it helping the
climate. So they're like, look, if we
just had a car-free Sunday, if we had
work-free Sundays, we could really help
the climate. So the climate activists
are all over this.
The Christians are all over it because
they're like, yeah, finally the world's
getting back to God. We need God in this
world.
It's true. We need God,
but not forced. God never forces
himself.
This is a a willful relationship that
God invites us to have. And when you
start mingling church and state and you
start forcing worship on any level, like
Trump said, make America pray again.
That is a forceful statement. You can't
make You can make America great by
making some changes, but you can't make
people pray unless it's by force.
That's a very interesting statement that
he has there.
Here it is. Happy Holy Week. Let's make
America pray again as we lead into Good
Friday and and Easter.
I encourage you to get a copy of the God
Bless the USA Bible.
This is Christian nationalism. This is
where things are headed.
And I'm not a politician. I don't even
keep up with this stuff,
but I know the occult world has been
prophesying that 2025 is going to be a
time when
demons are going to manifest in this
world. And right now we have the
military on the news saying we are in
communication with non-human
intelligences. We've been communicating
with these interdimensional beings since
the 1930s
and now they're openly having court
hearings about it.
Natural disasters, famines, pestilences,
demonic manifestations that are being
talked about in the courthouse.
The stage is being set.
Something huge is about to happen that's
going to this nation. AI is
going to take away 50% of jobs or more
and when that happens rapidly soon,
there's going to be a lot of hungry
people, which is going to cause chaos.
This world is going to be in utter
chaos.
And when that happens, Satan is going to
come out as the false Messiah doing
signs and wonders and miracles, fire
from heaven, healing, getting rid of
climate change, getting rid of
pandemics.
And all the world including atheists are
going to believe.
Millions of Christians who don't
understand the timeline of prophecy, how
when Christ returns, he's coming like
lightning shines from the east to the
west. We're going to be caught up to
meet the Lord in the air. The dead in
Christ are going to be caught up to meet
the Lord in the air and the wicked are
going to be are going to be consumed by
the brightness of his coming. He's not
going to be walking around performing
miracles. This is why it's so important
to study line upon line. Study God's
word. Know what it says. Understand the
the prophetic timeline. Satan's trying
to keep us distracted with work and
entertainment and all these things to
keep us out of God's word, to keep us
away from the truth because that's the
only way he can fool the entire world.
The only way he can deceive the entire
world is to fool us about where we live,
about prophetic timelines,
all these things, about God's
commandments.
I pray that this was eye-opening to you.
If you still have questions like I
thought Jesus was our Sabbath, all that,
remember Jesus said, I've come not to
destroy the law, but I've come to
fulfill it. He said until heaven and
earth pass away, not one jot or one
tittle will pass from the law. He said,
if you love me, keep my commandments. He
said, I am the Lord of the Sabbath.
That doesn't mean that he got rid of it.
It means that we serve the Lord of the
Sabbath.
When you read Hebrews, check it out. It
says that there still remaineth a day of
rest and that we should walk according
to the way he walked so that we will not
fall into doubt.
I pray this was eye-opening to you. If
it was, click a big thumbs up. It really
helps this message get out into the
algorithm. Share this with your family
and friends. If you're new, click
subscribe. Click that notification bell
so you won't miss another video. I
wanted to get this out ASAP. So there
were some little glitches. I'm going to
fix those, but I love you. I thank you.
We can't do this without you. If you
want to support this ministry,
you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org
and we have a donate button there. You
can pay through PayPal. If you want to
send a donation through Cash App, we
have Cash App. If you want to send a
donation through Venmo or Zelle, we
cannot thank you enough. This ministry
cannot exist without you. We stepped out
in faith, my wife and I stepped out in
faith 4 months ago to make this ministry
happen and we're trusting that God will
provide and every month we've seen him
provide. And it's just been amazing that
it's come through people like you. So
help us to help get this message out to
the world. We love you. We thank you.
I'm so glad you guys are here and we'll
see you next time on Candid Truth.